PeWdS PlEaSe PlAyY DokI dOkI
PLAY DOKI DOKI
u NEED to PlaYYY dOki Doki LiteratUUrrre
You should play doki doki literature club. Eh EH I know it looks kind of WhEEbBYy but it gets really fucked up after a while. It put me in blah blah blahh
PLAY DOKI DOKI LITERATURE CLUB ALREADY YOU LATE SHET *sseizureee*
Felix: **seizure**SHUT THE FUCK UP!
I knew about this game way before you weebs.....uhm--fake ass something......
Christian channel. But you know what? I'm curious about this game, so I will play it!
Thank you very much, and not because you're complaining about it.
Let's play Doki Doki Literature Club.
This game is not suitable for children or those who are easily disturbed.
Oh, so it's gonna be like one of those cute games that then turn really evil.
Individuals suffering from anxiety or depression may not have a safe experience
playing this game for content warnings, please visit-
Great!
By playing
Doki Doki Literature Club, you agree that you are at least 13 years of age
and you consent to your exposure of highly disturbing content.
Maybe I'm being a little too skeptic here right off the bat. With the amount of praise this game is getting,
it must be good. It must be good.
The art looks great, and it's a free game, too!
Did it just s-
Did it just say "Team Santo"? "Sant"? Oh?
Oh, I was not ready for this!! :D
Oho, I am lightly bobbing my head to this.. *bobbing head and dancing to music*
You groove you lose, and I lost!
Oh!
Okay, okay..
OK! Let's begin a new let's play, it's gonna be a daily series. It's been a while
hisashiburidesu, hehe~! (Japanese for "it's been a long time")
Someone, please kill me. If anyone would like to come in and pop one in the back while I played this that would be great.
Sayori: "Hey!!"
I see an annoying girl running towards me from the distance,
waving her arms in the air like she's totally oblivious to any attention she might draw to herself.
The girl is Sayori, my neighbor and good friend since we were children. You know, the kind of friend
you'll never see yourself making today, but it just kind of works out because you've known each other for so long?
We used to walk to school together on days like this, but starting around high school
she would oversleep more and more frequently and I would get tired of waiting up.
But if she's going to chase after me like this,
I almost feel better off running away. Wow, what a dick move, people used to do that when I was a kid.
However, I just sigh and idle in front of the crosswalk and let Sayori already catch up to me.
Sayori: HAhaHhAHhah! I overslept again, but I caught you this time
I'm not keeping that voice up. Maybe, but only because I decided to stop and wait for you.
Sayori: Ehhhhhhh, you say that like you were thinking about ignoring me!
That's mean, pEwdSipIE
Well, if people stare at you for acting weird,
then I don't want them to think we're a couple or something you're not that hot I'm sorry, *Marzia is hotter than you*
Sayori.
But you did wait for me after all.
I guess you don't have it in you to be me even if you want to.
I hate this character already. Whatever you say, Sayori.
EhEHeHEEee
We cross the street together and make our way to school. As we draw near, the street become increasingly
speckled with other student making their daily commute. By the way, pewdsipie,
have you decided on a club to join yet?
A club? I told you already I'm not interested in joining any clubs
I haven't been looking either.
That's not true! you told me you would join a club this year
Did I..?
I'm sure it's possible that I did in one of our many conversations where I
dismissively go along with whatever she was going on about.
Sayori likes to worry a little too much about me when I'm perfectly content
just getting by on average while spending my free time on games and anime. What a life to live!
I was talking about how I'm worried about
Worried that you won't learn how to socialize or have any skills before college
This bitch is telling me how to socialize, excuse me. "Your happiness is really important to me y'know?"
Oh, she's way over heads to us damn, and I know you're happy now
But I'd die at the thought of you becoming a neet in a few years because you're not used to the real world
You trust me, right?
Don't make me keep waiting about you
Alright alright I'll look at a few clubs if it makes you happy no promises though
"Will you at least promise me you'll try a little?" Okay, I guess I'll try with you dad YaAY
Why do I let myself get lectured by a carefree girl more than that I'm surprised to even let myself relent to her
I guess seeing her worry so much about me makes me want to ease her mind at least a little bit
Even if she does exaggerate everything inside her head
We're in school hi everybody the school day is this ordinary as ever and it's over before I know it
But that's not how school works. Okay. It's never over before you know it
After I pack up my things I start blankly at the wall looking for an ounce of motivation clubs
Sayori wants me to check out some clubs. I guess I have no choice, but to start with the anime club
heLL0oO?!
Sayori
Sorry must have come into the classroom while I was spacing out
I look around and realize that I'm the only one left in the classroom
If Ana kid she came in out of the class name, but I figured you City history a through K me
and if me you even waive immunity Amy breathe
You don't need to wait up for me
our voices sucked up
Okay, it's going to make you late to your own Club. We say you may need to me keeps me in retaking game
You know what weird if you can Kingdom eager you say hurry?
There's no way I'm going to your club
Savories vice president of the literature club that sounds really boring
Not that I was ever aware that she had any interest in literature in fact
I'm 99% sure she only did it because she thought it would be fun to help start a new club
Since she was the first one to show interest after the one who proposed a club. She inherited the title vice president
That said my interest in literature is guaranteed to be even less
Yeah, I'm going to the anime club
Why do you care so much anyway
I
Can't do it clip yesterday. I would bring a new baby
And that's tsukimi cupcake is it everything well
She made
Yeah, you have to go now
Don't make promises you can't keep
I can't tell if C. Or E is really that much of an airhead or if she's so cunning
I start playing all this app I
Let alone say hey
Bang a set by for a cupcake okay
Let's go
And that's today marks a day I sell my soul for a cupcake what I?
DJ. Glee follow saber across the school in upstairs a section
of the school
I rarely visit being generally used for third year classes and activities, so I already full of energy swings open the classroom door
Everyone then a member is he I told you don't call me a new member. Hey, I glanced around the room
Welcome to the literary Claire - Claire Claire Claire
This is why I don't do reading games Jesus Christ, it's a pleasure meeting you
Sayuri so who is next says old
Sailor it always says nice things about you. Oh my god. What voice?
Series
Seriously you brought a boy wait. I'll get it eventually way to kill the atmosphere I
Pizza bear what a nice surprise
Welcome to the clip
All words escape me in this situation this club is full of incredibly cute girls
Wow which one is your wife
The younger sister the older sister or perhaps dead girl next door type leave a comment now
Sorry netsuke
The girl with the sour attitude whose name is apparently netsuke is
One I don't recognize her small figure makes me think she's probably a first-year. She is also the one who made cupcakes according to saiary
Already says that quietly into my ear then turns back towards the other girls
Don't say things like that it
Yuri you appears complete
Compared ibly more mature and timid seems to have a hard time keeping up with people like say you're a nut Sookie
oh, well, it's nice to meet both of you, and it seems like you already know money can say 3
That's right. It's great to see you again pizza pay oh
Wow tits out Monica smiles, sweetly
We don't know each other. Well. We rarely talk, but we were in the same class last year
Monica is that really a Japanese name. I never heard it
Monica was probably the most public or in class smart beautiful athletic
Nice rack basically completely out of my league so having her smile at me so genuinely feels a little
Get the cupcakes hey, I made them out get up
Then how about I make some tea as well
the girls have a few deaths arranged to form a table as
Sayuri mentioned, it's been widened so that there is one space next to Monica and one space next to Sayuri
Net so Ian and Yuri walk over to the corner of the room
We're not see you grabs a rap tray, and you're reopens the closet still feel like awkward. I take a seat next to Sayuri
Maybe this club isn't so bad after all netsuke proudly marches back to the table train hane
Okay, are you ready?
That's icky lift the foil of the the train to real adult dozen white
Fluffy cupcakes decorated to look like little cats. Oh my god. That is so cute
The whiskers are drawn with icing and little pieces of chocolate were used to make ears. Oh my god. That is so cute
Sachi
I had no idea you were so good at baking Natsuki. He will you know?
Just hurry. Just hurry up and take what I mean. Oh fine Sayuri grabs one first then Monica I follow
Sayuri walk talks with her mouth full and has already managed to get icing on her face I
Turned the cupcake around in my fingers looking for the best angle to take a back
Netsuke is quiet
I can't help but notice her sneaking glances in my direction if she is she waiting for me to take a bite
I finally buy damn
The icing is sweet and full of flavor. I wondered if she made it herself
This is really good
Thank You netsuke
Why do you think me? It's not like hey haven't I heard this somewhere before?
Made them for you or anything oh
hey, I
Thought technically you did say or he said well, maybe
But not for you you you
dummy alright alright I
give up on that Sookie's weird logic and dismissed the
conversation
URI returns to the table carrying a tea set she carefully
Places a teacup in front of each of us before setting down the tea pot next to the cupcake tray
Where's the literature in this club okay, so far? It's just girls and sweets
You keep a whole tea set in the classroom
Don't worry the teachers give us permission
After all doesn't it hot cup of tea help you enjoy a good book fair enough. I guess uh, I guess what Jesus
Hey, hey, hey, don't let yourself get intimidated. You're just trying to impress e
And that's not it
Insulted URI looks away. I mean that you know I
Believe you well tea and reading might not be a past time for me, but at least
But at least I enjoy tea, I'm glad you're a faintly smiles herself in relief what the hell is happening here
Monica raises an eyebrow then smash at me
So what made you consider literature clip?
I was afraid of this question something tells me. I shouldn't tell Monica that I was practically dragged here by syuri
Well I haven't joined any club's yet, and she always seemed really happy here, so
That's a great reason as any oh sorry, that's okay. Don't be embarrassed
We'll make sure you feel right at home, okay as
president of
Literature club, it's my duty to make the club fun and exciting for MPP
Monica I'm surprised how come you decided to start your own Club? You could probably be a board member for any of the major clubs
Where's your leader of the Bay Club last year Hey, so you know?
To be honest I can't stand no the politics around the major Cape
if it's like nothing, but arguing about the budget and publicity and how to prepare for events I
Much rather take something I personally enjoy and make something special atomy and if it encourage others to get into literature
Then I'm fulfilling that tree
Really great leader
Yuri nods in agreement
Then I'm surprised there aren't more people in the club yet. It must be hard to start a new club
You could put it you could paint it that way
Not many people are very interested in putting out all the effort
To start something brand new especially when it's something that doesn't grab your attention like literature
You have to work hard to convince people that you're both fun and worthwhile
But it makes cool events like the festival much more important. I'm
confident that we can really grow this club before we graduate read every when
We'll do our best
Everyone
Enthusiastically agrees what a great time?
Such different girls all interested in the same goal
My dear Monika must have worked really hard just to find these three
Maybe that's why they were all so delighted by the idea of a new member joining
Though I still don't really know if I can keep up with their level of enthusiasm about literature
So pizza pay what kind of things do you like to read well?
Considering how low I've read these past few years. I don't really have a good way of answering that manga I
mutter quietly to myself half joking
Netsuke ahead Matt Sookie's head suddenly except. It looked like she wants to say something, but she keeps quiet
Not much of a reader egg yes
Well that can change what am I saying? I?
Spoke without thinking after seeing your sad smile
Anyway, what about you jury Yuri? Well, let's see Yuri traces
the remembers she kept with her finger
My favorites are usually novice that build deep and complex fantasy worlds
The level of creativity and craftsmanship behind them is amazing to me and telling a good story in such a foreign world is equally impressive
Yuri goes on clearly passionate about her reading
She seems so reserved and timid since the moment I walked in
But it's obvious by the way her eyes lit up that she finds her comfort in the world of books not people
But you know I like a lot of things stories with deep psychological m. Elements usually emerged me as well
Isn't it amazing how a radicand so deliberately take advantage of your lack of imagination to completely, throw you off for a loop?
Foreshadowing everybody
Anyway, I've been reading a lot harder lately
foreshadowing again, ah I've read a hard book once I
Desperately grass something I can relate to at a minimum level at this rate. You might as well be having a conversation with the rock
really I
Wouldn't have expected that Yuri
for someone as gentle as you I
Guess you could say that
But if a story makes you think or takes me to another world, then I really can't put it down
So real horror is often very successful at shake changing the way you look at the world if only for a brief moment oh
Why is that weird I just
That's against I start over to me for a split second
This is so strange. What is happening what am I doing?
Never mean
That's right. Usually like to create a pet usually right - right
Usually like to write about cute things don't you netsuke
You left a piece of scrap paper behind last Club meeting it looked like you were working on a poem called
Give it back fine fine. Yeah, your kid kicks knee pains
Everything you do is
Justice Kennedy what?
Say he or ISIL is up behind. That's again puts a hand or in the shoulder. I'm not cute
that's the key you write your own poems I
Guess some teams. Where do you keep I think that's impressive?
Why did you share them sometime? Yeah? That's a giver to rice we did late-teen ah?
Not a very confident writer yet I
understand how netsuke feels
sharing that level of writing
Takes more than just confidence
The truest form of writing is writing that one writing to oneself you
Must be willing to open up to your readers exposing your vulnerabilities and showing even the deepest reaches of your heart
Do you have a riding
experience to Yuri
maybe if you share somebody we work you can set an example and help nesic it feel more comfortable enough to share her I
Guess it's the same for Yuri
We all sit in silence for a moment okay, I have an idea everyone
Nuts again your liquid quiz a galley ad Monica
Let's all go home and write a poem of our own
Then next time we meet we'll all share them with each other that way everyone is even
Plus
Now that we have a new member
I think it will help us all get a little more comfortable with each other and strengthen the bond of the club
Isn't that rad Pizza pay?
Money get smiles warmly at you once again
Hold on. There's still one problem. Yeah, but it's dead
Now that we're back to the original topics of me joining the club
I bluntly came forward with what's been on my mind the entire time
I never said I would join this club
Sayuri may have convinced me to stop by, but I never made any decision I
still have other clubs to look at and I
Lose my train of thought all four girls stare back at me with dejected eyes
How can you say no to for I am a wife who's just one maybe to hell no three
I rather burn in hell for you. Just can't
but
I'm sorry, I thought
You want oh, I different, I'm defenseless again these girls how am I supposed to make it clear headed decision when it's like this
That's if that is if writing poems a surprise. I need to pay in order to spend it every day with these beautiful girls
Right, okay? I've decided
I'll join the literature Club everybody yay
One by one the girl's eyes lit up
Sayuri wraps her arms around me jumping up and down oh
You really did scare me for a moment
If you really just came in for cupcakes I would be super pissed
Then that makes it official
Welcome to the literature Club yay. Ah
Thanks, I guess
Okay, everyone. I think with that we can officially end today's meeting on a good now
Everyone remember tonight's assignment write a poem to bring the next meeting so we can all share Monica looks over at me once more
Pizza pie I look forward to seeing how you express yourself
Yeah
Okay, can I really impress the class star Monica with my motive mediocre writing skills? I already feel anxiety welling up inside me
Meanwhile the girls continue to chitchat at URI and nastika clean up their food
That's right saya, and I never walk home together anymore because she always stayed after school for Cleanse sure might as well
With that the two of us depart the club room and make our way home
The whole way my mind wanders back and forth between the four girls
Sayuri
nesic Yuri and of course Monica well
I really will I be will I really be happy spending every day after school in a literature Club perhaps
I'll have the chance to grow closer to one of these girls all right
I'll just need to make the most of my circumstances
And I'll make sure a good fortune will find me and I guess that starts with writing a poem tonight
Wait I actually have to write a poem what big words you think your favorite club member will like
Something good might happen with whoever likes are pulling the most what?
Okay, so I'm gonna go with
Wait there was nuts Akita Yuri, and Yuri, I think Yuri is my Bey
That but
So extraordinary death Marshman so she like horrors right? That's what I picked up on so let's go with death
And she liked fantasy horror no actually like that one, okay?
Adventure, maybe all she liked adventure
Love oh my god, I'm picking all the wrong
Agonizing okay, she really likes all the bad stuff sadness what?
Kitty's definitely
Pure fuck this is hard man anchor of course. That's her
Uncanny yes frightening yes easy
Reid was our nice gravy our dessert as well melancholies her
Fantasies what
Captive
Inferno fear what
Oh
I don't know who we impressed here actually
Hey again Pizza Bay glad to see you didn't run away from us. Hahaha I
Took a quick break glad to see you didn't run away on us hey
Man, don't worry
This might be a little strange for me, but at least keep my word. I at least keep my word. Well, I'm
Back at literature Club. I was the last to come in so everyone else is already hanging out
Thanks for keeping your promise pizza pay. I hope this isn't too overwhelming of a commitment for you
Making you dive headfirst into literature when you're not accustomed to it
Come on, rocky deserves any slack
Sigh you already told me you didn't even want to join any clips if you
and last year - I
Don't know if you plan to just come here and hang out or what?
Hoping to get some ass boy
Hell yeah, I'll join any literature club
Buddy, but if you don't take us seriously, then you won't see the end of it
Netsuke you You certainly have a big mouth for everyone who keeps her manga collection in the club room oh
Singha but dinga
That's a good find yourself stuck between saying Monica and manga
We swiftly defeated Natsuki perhaps plugs back in there into her seat
If you mean baby were giving me a key
Make it clean. I mean how dependable?
Say all right. That's because your room is so messy. It's distracting and you almost set your house on fire once
You two are really good friends. Thank you. I might be a little jealous
Hey, you need pizza kid became become
Sayuri
As usual Sayuri seems oblivious to the weird situation you just put me into oh
yeah, even
sympathy you know
wait Sayuri
me
not really, Debbie, Shh
It's really nothing
What what is it? Yeah? Never made say? We made it sound like a big deal when it's really not
What do I do II I'm sorry Yuri. I wasn't thinking I
Guess that means it's up to me to rescue this situation
Hey
Don't worry about it first of all I wasn't expecting anything in the first place so any nice gesture from you is a pleasant surprise
It'll make me happy no matter what?
Is is that so?
Yeah, I won't make it a big deal if you don't want it to be
all right, well here Yuri reaches into her bag and pulls out a book I
Didn't want you to feel left out so I picked out a book that I thought you might enjoy Oh
Best girl you're a
It's a short read, so it should keep your attention even if you don't usually read Oh best girl
And we could you know?
Read it together
Discuss it if you wanted this
This is how it's this girl accidentally being so cute. She even picked out a book she thinks. I like despite me
Not me natural reading like you're a thank you. I'll definitely read this I
enthusiastically take the book
Hey
Well, you can read it at your own pace. I look forward to hearing what you think?
Now that everyone settled in I expect Monica to kick up some schedule activities for the club, but that doesn't seem to be the case
Sayuri and Monika are heading having a cheery conversation in the corner your his face is already buried in a book
I can't help but notice her intense expression like his weight when she was waiting for this chance
Maybe not Sookie's rum rummaging around in the closet
Man it looks like no one wants to be bothered today I
Slumped down into the nearest desk how am I supposed to occupy myself with something literature related by myself like this
I guess I could always read some of the book
Yuri gave me obviously that's the right thing to do right now
But I'm feeling a little too tired to believe I could probably fall asleep right now
I close my eyes and end up listening and on your thyroids conversation with Monika
Could be Julie the clip see
Hmm well we can't give up the festival is our chance to show everyone what there
It sure is all about the problem
Is that the idea of literature Club serves to dense and intellectual to be fair you have must have extremely high IQ?
But it's not like that at all
You know we just need a way of showing that to everyone something that speaks to their creative minds
They didn't send a bindi
What do you mean?
Even if we commit with the most friending
ami-nee busy Willie came in first, please
Lyrics Jeremy they was very important to figure it out you get people to show up in the first place no
limping
And after they came we can do it the thing to speak to that greeted me
What is this Sierra's taking this really seriously?
It's rare to hear her deliberately likely
Talking deliberate hmm. That's a good point
In that case do you think food will do the trick you ain't King well, I guess we could
Good thinking
You invited all my friends good thinking oh hi my nuts hi Monica. That's the kid would love to do that
That's a comedic base camp geeks
That works perfectly
That wasn't why you suggested it. Haha get cake baking
Cupcakes it is then
Anyway we still need to work out the details of the event itself I
Find myself smiling in the end Sayuri is still her usual self by therein lies the
Unexpected reason I admire her no
No
You don't like her unlike me was trouble finding any motivation at all
Sayuri can put her mind to things and make them come to life, I suppose
That's why I ended up letting her get on my case about things
I can't help but wonder what it would be like to see the world through her eyes
That's too close
I
Opened my eyes to find se or his face filling my vision. I nearly fought out of my chair
Wait it's Mia material it's your foot sleeping like that
That's our school really have a napping Club
You sing a plea to get Nicky
Never you in a collab you can have this tape for any meanie
You know it needs to be don't say that so loud. I glanced over my shoulder to see if Monica overheard
It's true
Yeah, I know. I know you're always looking out for me so Yuri
That's the problem
What about you you look out for me better than you look out for yourself. You're still over sleeping every day aren't you?
That's not very convincing how many days is past week have you gotten up on time I?
Know it
Meda pretty pretty Tootsie, I can't even do that look say you're a it's written all over you II
Say a glances around herself hey
You were clearly in a rush this money look your hair is sticking out all around here. I
Run my fingertips down the side of sailors say you were here trying to straighten out oh, oh that's a good move
That's a good move, man
you really need to brush this for this my
Really educate me. I won't fall for that
There's more than just your hair
Look your bow isn't straight either and there's two-faced stain in your collar right there? I?
Try to wipe off the stick oh
That's in that. That's in the Titov region
Of course they would
Nobody's gonna tell you about it because they don't want you to embarrass you fortunately. I don't care about that
And you don't even keep your blazer button up seriously saiary why do you think you don't have a boyfriend yet?
Me
Sorry, but you'll thank me later
I'll start to putting our blazer from the button once you see how much better looks you'll change your mind
What is
A miss just thinking do we really strive a friend you did see Kensie? Hey?
Don't say that you'll make me feel weird and stupid about it
Vicky do in hippie really please ah
I guess he be careful the bread you might cut
Ha
Why is this one so hard of course I
Struggle to fully close the paneer a chick
Does this thing even fit you properly
Did we make Betty Oh
If you ever button it you would have noticed sooner that it doesn't fit you anymore, what are you smiling about?
Don't say that out loud
Anyway you look much better now so uh
Why does it feel strange to see Sayuri's blazer burn up like that but it's so tough?
This is really strange for me to read. I hope you'd realize that
Sorry hey something I brought us our blazing ones more
Syrup it's arms are out and twirls around so if I keep eating Peyton Danny won't get away from me
What kind of logic is that?
and why are you saying that that's like a good thing because
If I hit it boyish pretty, then he wouldn't make me you deceive cookie
And you take medicating me than anyone else would anyway
So that's why I keep I'm keeping it unbuttoned
stop saying all these impaired things things if I didn't say anything embarrassing II
Jeez, well anyway just focus on trying to wake up a little earlier. Oh
Only if you focus on getting to be really
Fine fine, it's a deal. I guess be really are better taking care of each other. Then we are taking care of our teeth
Yeah, I guess so huh, so maybe you should
Come wake me up this morning
You're doing it again say re
Happy I was joking with you
But it's impossible to tell with you sometimes okay, everyone. Thank god someone else
Hey Monica. Suddenly calls out. Why don't we share our poems the pose we wrote now
I can't wait to read this
Yeah, the same I fail to sound enthusiastic, but serious still trots a way to retrieve her poem by the way
Do you did you remember to write a poem last night?
Yeah, my relaxation ends. I can't believe I agreed to do something so embarrassing I
Couldn't really find much inspirations as I never really done this before
Well now that everyone's ready why don't you find someone to share with?
Okay, wait
Say, you're a Monica enthusiatic pull out their poems
I'm really curious about this poem thing say your is on wrinkle sheet of loose-leaf torn from a spiral notebook
On the other hand Monica wrote her sin come in a composition notebook
I can already see Monica spray pristine handwriting from where I sit. That's again
You reluctantly complies while reaching into their bags. I do the same myself
I kinda wants a orys poem first
I'm
Definitely most compared comfortable sharing it with Sayuri first. She's my good friend after all oh, it's who I share it with
No I babysit to keep reading
Sayuri
You must be seriously overreacting
I'm not a good writer at all I
Honestly have no idea what I'm doing waiting. Maybe this way because I
wouldn't either ha ha
Geez I'm sure yours opinion has to be a little bit more constructive than this maybe even at Sookie's are
You sure you don't like it. Just because I wrote it
I'm sure this party. I think I understand you better than a lot of people you know
So when I read you pain
It's not just
it's
Like I can feel your spirit
Sara hugs the sheet against her chest you're so weird saiary, she clearly wants to fuck
Me huh you're really pretty believe me not to mention the fact that I'm standing in front of you in the clubroom
Well of course. I'm not really into yet, but that doesn't mean I'll break my promise see
Before it's be deep, then you see if it is you know Tran new things for other people
That's everything only really good critic
Thanks a hurry
I'm not sure if they already sees the full picture of my motive him then again
I can't deny that she's part of the reason. I joined knowing how much this means to her at all
I'm gonna make sure you have necer finger, okay
There would be my way of thank you all right. I'm going to hold you to do that then hey
Now your emag going to me. Don't worry. I'm really beat it
We'll see about that
It makes me feel like you missed me
Kissing my forehead to help me out of bed
Making me rub. Did I sleepy from my eyes?
Are you asking me to commit and play are you testing for me to wish where we are' needy?
Look up at the sky blue
It's a secret, but I be trusted to if it wasn't for you. I would sleep forever oh
Sorry
This is just a guess, but did you wait until this morning to write this?
No
She said it'll be
You can't answer just a little bit - a yes-or-no question I'd forget to do at least me
Well at least that makes me feel a little better at myself. Do you be me? I don't think it was that bad. Oh?
And because she said I won't break this
Icy creamy beat oh yeah, I didn't mean to say that it was a bad poem
It came out nice, or how should I put it? It sounds just like you?
Yeah, especially the last line
Even though you were late to school, it's
Babies creaky well, I guess there's no point in arguing anyway. Thanks for showing me
Monica's
Beep oh yeah, but next time I won't forget
And I'm gonna write the big poof ever
Well, I guess I'll I look forward to all right, so let's go Yuri next
Hmm
Yuri stares at the poem a minute pass is more than enough time for her to finish reading oh
Sorry I forgot to start speaking um
It's fine. Don't force yourself
I'm not I just need to put my thoughts into words
Hold on. Okay. This is your first time writing a poem right?
Yeah
Why do you ask I'm just making sure I guess that he might be after reading through it. Oh
So it's that bad. Huh, No?
Did I just raise my voice? Oh? I'm sorry
Yuri bears her face in her hands I
couldn't help but notice that it it's been several minutes, and we really haven't gotten no anyway I
Might take Yuri, and oh it might take your a while to get used to new people it's fine. I didn't
notice
What you were saying?
Right um. It's just that there are specific writing habits that are usually typical of new writers and having been through that myself
I kind of learned to pick up on them. I think the most notable thing I recognize in new writers
Is that they try to make their style very?
Deliberate in other words they tend to pick a writing style separate from the topic matter and they form fit the two together
The inner soul is that both the style and the expressiveness are weakened once you refines her train of thought
It's as if her demeanor totally changes her stammering is completely gone as she sounds like an expert of course
That's not something you can be blamed for there are so many different skills and techniques that go into writing even a single poet
I'm not just finding them and building them
But getting them to work together is probably the most challenging part it might take you some time
But it all comes with practice and learning by example and trying new things
I also hope that everyone else in the club makes you value make gives you valuable feedback
Netsuke can be a be a little biased though. Why is how?
well nevermind I
Shouldn't be talking about people like that. Sorry. It's okay
I'm not sure if you is apologizing to herself to me or not Sookie
Do you mind if I read your poem now, please?
Do I'd love to share my thought process behind it Hira smiles dreaming Lee as if that's a rare opportunity for her
Which itself is kind of funny after all isn't this supposed to be a literature Club
Ghost under light the tendo's of my hair
Illuminates beneath the amber glow bathing it must be this one
The last remaining streetlight to have withstood the test of time
The last yet to be replaced by the sickening blue green hue of the future
I bathe calm breathing air of the present by living in the past the light flickers I
flicker back that was beautiful
I'm I'm sorry. I have such terrible handwriting
What I wasn't thinking that at all
but it took you so long to read ah
Well, I just don't read scripts very often. I actually think your handwriting is pretty
Hey
That's a relief
Also, I like the column even though it's short. It was really didn't scripted
it wasn't too short I
Usually write longer puns not at all. I'm really glad you like it
I'll be honest since it's our first time sharing. I wanted to write something a little more mild
Something easy to judge digest I suppose
Are you into ghosts Yuri? Oh?
Yuri means ghost in Japanese if he
Actually the story or is it you may know I don't know
Now I'm confused
actually the story isn't about ghosts at artbeads Bay really I
Must have totally missed the point
Well, I suppose you did only glanced over it after all but remember that poems often express their own thoughts feelings and experience in their
work
They usually do more than tell a simple story or paint a picture in this case perhaps the subject of the poem is only being
symbolically compared to a ghost
Lingering in her last remaining place of comfort unable to let go over the past and soon to be left with nothing
That's a lot more solemn putting it that way
I'd even thought of that that's impressive. It's nothing really
Well, it makes me happy that you think that just remember that it won't be long before you pick up on these things, too
Yeah, maybe you're right. I guess I'll have to keep trying. I'm counting on you alright. We got two more
We'll end with Monica I think Oh
God
Well it's about what I experienced from someone like you
That's a little pun when excuse me. It's not like it's like I said it was bad. I
Just didn't walk in emotions
So basically it's not cute enough for your taste
Do you want to get smacked?
I'll pass right
There anyway, I need to show you mine. I like you like
Eagles can fly monkeys can climb
crickets can leap horses can race
I'll skim seat to the skin Braund Eagles can fly people can try, but that's about it
What in the world yeah, I told you you weren't gonna like it I like it what
Just be honest I am
wait why are you so convinced that I wouldn't like it well because
Everyone high school things that running has to be all sophisticated stuff, so people don't even take my writing seriously
But isn't the point of poems too for people to express himself your writing style. It wouldn't make your message any less valley
yes, exactly I
Like when it's easy to read, but it's it's but it hits your hair like in this piece
So you never wonder right they do great things. Give me really disheartening
So I decided to write a bit
Yeah, I understand
But the other nice thing about simple writing is that it puts more weight on the word play
Like it's set up for a rhyme at the end, but then made it all flat on purpose
It helps bring out the feeling in the last layer
So you did I guess more went into it than I realized I liked her poem
Why am I reading poems in a videogame, and I'm genuinely entertained by it
That's what it means to me
I'm glad you learned something I didn't expect that from you the youngest one of you
Did you I guess not you didn't expect that Burnett? I?
decide to humor her with the last comment I
Don't really care. How old everyone is, but if netsuke is feeling proud then I won't take that away from her alright where Monica left
Hype, it's Bank having a good time so far. Oh, yeah good
glad to hear it by the way since you're new and everything if
You ever have any suggestion for the club like new activities or things we can do better
I'm always listening don't be afraid to bring things up okay alright. I'll keep that in mind of course
I'll be afraid to bring things up I'm much better off. Just going with the flow and not until I'm more settled in anyway
Want to share your pond with me it's kind of embarrassing, but I guess I have to
Hey
Don't worry pizza pan bro a little embarrassed you know
But it's sort of buried that we all learn to get past soon. Yeah, that's true
I had Mona get my pun hmm. I like this one
It makes me think of something Sayuri would like is that so you and Cirie are really good friends, right I?
Wouldn't be surprised if you had those sort of things in coming. Oh well
Hey, we may be good friends, but saya and I are actually really different hmm
Well that may be the case, but maybe there are also similarities that you wouldn't expect
The way she talks about you. It sounds like you two are really care about each other well be
Even if you show it in different ways it ends up being more similar than you think
So I think that's the kind of vibe I get when reading your poem
You sure you're not reading into this too much
Ha ha ha it could be oh gosh
I sound like Yuri, but in any case Sara's writing has a has kind of a gentle feel to it
I can tell she likes exploring with emotions like happiness and sadness
Who knew that someone so happy would enjoy it sad things too. I wish we had clubs in our schools
It seems so great. Maybe it's just glorified for obviously well. We'll see where he goes. Yeah, that's totally unexpected
Well each to our own you shouldn't be afraid to experiment a little bit either
I'm sure I'll end up trying different things online
It could take a while before I feel comfortable doing this that's ok. I love to see you try new things
That's the best way to find the kind of style that suits you
Everyone else might be a little bit biased towards their own kind of styles, but I always help you find. What suits you the most
So don't force yourself to write the way everyone else wants you to write
It's not like you have to worry about impressing them or anything ha ha ha ha ha
Anyway, do you want to read my poem? Now? Don't worry. It's not very good
You sounded pretty confident for someone who claimed to not be very good
Well, that's because I have to sound confident that doesn't mean I always feel that way. You know I sink well. Let's me
Hole in the wall
It couldn't have been me
see the direction the spackle protrudes a
Noisy neighbor an angry boyfriend. I never know I wasn't home I
Peer inside it for a clue no
I can't see I real blind like a film left out of the Sun, but it's too late my retinas
Already scorched with a permanent copy of the meaningless image. It's just a little hole. It wasn't too bright. It was too deep
stretching forever into everything a hole of infinite choices
I realized now that I wasn't looking in I was looking now
and he on the other side was looking in I
Was a glory hole I
Like you, so what do you think?
Hmm, it's very freedom if that's what you call. It. Sorry. I'm not really the right person to ask for feedback
That's okay. Yeah, that kind of style has gotten pretty popular nowadays
That is a lot of poems. I've been putting emphasis on timing between words and lines
When performing out loud it can be really powerful
What was the inspiration behind this one?
Well I'm not sure I know how to put it I guess you could say that I had some kind of epiphany recently
It's been influencing in sing my palms tipping an epiphany
Yeah something like that
I'm kind of nervous to talk about deep stuff like that because it's kind of coming on strongly
Maybe after everyone is better friends with each other
Anyway, here's Monica's writing tip of the day
Some sometimes when you're writing a poem or a story your brain gets to fix it get
Fixated on a specific point if he tries so hard to make it perfect then you'll never make any progress
Just force yourself to get something down on the paper and tied it up later
Another way to think about it is this if you keep your pen in the same spot for too long
You'll get a big dark puddle of ink so just move your hand and go with the flow that's my advice for today
Thanks for listening
Whoo I guess that's everyone I glanced around the room that was a little more stressful than I anticipated
It's as if everyone is judging me for my mediocre writing abilities. Even if they're just being nice
There's no way my opponents can stand up to theirs
This is a literature club after all I say hey
I guess that's what I ended up getting myself
Into across the room so you're in Monica are happily chatting my aunt's land on Uranus Sookie
They gingerly exchange sheets of paper saying there
Respective puns as they read in tandem
I watched each of their expression change Matt's eglise eyebrows furrow in frustration meanwhile, Yuri smiled sadly
Did you say something
Because they are the complete opposites
that's a good dismissal lady returns upon to the desk with one hand I guess you could say it's Fifi ah
Thanks
Your sis here
Did you complete did he completely miss the symbolism or something it's clearly about feeling never giving up
How can that be cute I?
Know that I just meant the language
I guess I was trying to say something nice Hey
You mean you have to try to it been hard to come up with something nice to say
Thanks, but that really didn't come and ate it oh um well I do have a couple of suggestions
If I was looking for suggestion I would have asked someone who actually liked it
Which people date by the way that you're related inputs if I dictum
Sir Bateson dead. I gladly give you some detention of my own fate the boat
Excuse me. I appreciate the effort, but I spent a long time in
Satellite Excel, I don't expect it to change anytime soon unless of course
I come across something particularly inspiring which I haven't yet and
Pizza pie like my poem to you now. He even told me he was impressed by it
That's a oh that's a good son disdain. Set oh
I didn't realize you were so impressed
invested in trying to impress and remember Yuri
Hey, that's not what I uh? Yeah, you just you raise ends up as well
Maybe you're just jealous that pizza pie appreciated my advice more than he appreciated yours
And how do you know we didn't appreciate my advice move are you bad full of your shoe?
cat buy
Know if I was full of myself I would deliver to go out of my way to mix everything. I do overly cutesy oh
Well you know what I wasn't the one whose boobs
Magically grew a size bigger as soon as pity buy started showing up
netsuke
Netsuke, that's a little
This doesn't involve you
Make face
Suddenly both girls turn towards me as if they just noticed. I was standing there
Pizza pack she's just trying to make me look bad
If she could get over herself and learn to proceed, but simple reading is more effective, then this wouldn't have happened in the factory
What's the point of making your poem all concluded for no reason that the meaning should jump?
I don't that read it not forth into a difficulty
It may explain it to repeats me
Wait there's a reason we have so many deep and expressive words in our language
It's the only way to convey complex feeling and meaning the most effectively
Avoiding them is not only unnecessary limiting yourself. It's also a waste you understand that right pizza pie ah
Well
How did I get dragged into this in the first place
It's not like I know anything about writing, but whoever I agree with they'll probably think more highly of me
That's a key, that's a googly eyes. Let me drying up any words. I had in my mouth, so instead I turn to Yuri
Yuri expressions, so defenseless that I can't bring myself to say anything to her
Sorry, yeah, everyone is fighting is making to say you're uncomfortable
How can you two keep fighting when you know you're making your friend feel like this
PGP
Well, that's her. That's her problem. This isn't about her. Hey I agree
It's unfair for others to interject their own feelings into our conflict
Yeah, at least Yuri wants to tell Yuri. What a stuck-up jerk? She's be?
Shh she would never
It's Yuri maturity that made her upset in the first place excuse me are you lit?
Exactly way everybody here exactly where nobody likes dead
Vicky Gary I get it my friend I said you might never went to get along and be happy
My friends and wonderful people
Nothing because definitely
it being
Do you mean, but could they give them any feelings? It's okay wait?
I mean it's being a beautiful beginning my hey
Everybody's so damn deep do everything
because
well if
Magic is cutie dick. Nothing ray mutated, and you in space are the same eating very sweet
bacon, baby face
Naomi sour saiary it stands triumphantly monica's stands behind her will denies expression
What did I just say
I'll make some tea you're really rush this up. That's a guess. It's down with a blank expression on her face staring at nothing
So this is why I say Yura is wise president. I whisper to Monica she nods in return to be honest
I might come off as a good leader, and I can organize things, but I'm not very good with people
I couldn't even bring myself to interject as president. That's kind of embarrassing to me, huh?
Nah, it's like I can't blame you. I wasn't able to say anything either well
I guess I mean Sarah is amazing in her own ways isn't she?
You could say that she might be an airhead, but sometimes. It's weirdly suspicious that she knows exactly what she's doing I
See take good care of her okay? I
Would hate to see her again
herself hurt
That makes the two of us you can count on me Monica smiles sweetly at me causing my stomach tonight
She's such a gent
Such a genuine person really does make a good president regardless of what she says if only I could get a chance to talk to
Her a little bit more
Okay, everyone. It's just about time for us to leave how did you feel about sharing phones?
Well I
I'd say was Bertha
He was all right, but we'll mostly pizza pie how about you? Yeah? I'd say the same
It was neat thing to talk about with everyone
awesome in that case
we'll do the same thing tomorrow, and maybe you learned something from your French team so your opponents will turn out even better I
Think to myself I did learn a little bit more about the kind of poems everyone likes
With any luck that means I can at least do a better job impressing those
I want to I'm out to myself with new found determination
really t weiqi
Sure, let's go
Say already beam send me it truly has been a wireless and say Orion has spent this much time together
I can't really say I'm not enjoying it either
Sorry about what happened earlier
What do you mean? You know between uranus aki does that thing happen often no?
It's really the first time. It's independently
They promise a proof when you compete
You don't you don't hate the deep?
No, I don't hate them. I just wanted your opinion. That's all I can see why they make good friends with you
It's nice that I got to spend time with you in the clip
But I think you don't mean everyone is make me the hey beat, and I think everyone likes it a that's hey
Every day is going to be famous V
Sign it looked like sailor is still hasn't caught on to the counter situation that made sure being friends with everything is nice
But this I really need to stop here. We'll just have to see what the future holds saiary
IPad so Yuri on the shoulder I said that more to myself than to her
But it's easy to use say or ES and internal monologue sometime. Okay. Yeah, let's do this I
Have to write another poem
Let's do that in the next episode
Really enjoying this game
It's really well done
I'm really kidding me. You know what plot twist is coming and but
I'm just enjoying it for what it is right now surprisingly. I hope you enjoy it as well if you did
I really appreciate leaving and like
Sharing this watching this and then seeing you tomorrow in another episode
Squad Fam... Out.